[Applause]
welcome back
doesn't this just sound like the perfect
dream a robot
that can pour you a glass of wine it's
just one of the gadgets on display at
this year's all digital
ces 2021 rich demuro explains on today's
tech smart
ces might be known for its eye-catching
tvs that seem to get bigger and bigger
and sharper every year
but there are so many gadgets to
discover here's a look at some of this
year's
unique finds
[Music]
ces 2021 is swapping slot machines for
streaming
the show has gone all digital due to the
pandemic it really gave us an
opportunity to pivot and really focus on
what we could do to bring the digital
part of ces to life
it's ces 2021 thanks for watching i've
been hosting a live show along with
internet personality ijustine
i always have so many incredible ces
memories and it's sort of how i start my
year and it kind of really
sets the stage for what we can expect to
have in the future with tech while
there's no show floor in las vegas to
rome there are still
plenty of gadgets being announced tcl
showing off a phone screen that
stretches to become bigger
and a 17-inch screen that rolls out like
a scroll
samsung's new bot handy robot helps out
with household chores
and can even grab you a glass of wine
now
cars have intel inside the company laid
out plans for its mobile eye chips which
power
autonomous vehicles it is being able to
build the scene
to an accuracy level that no single car
can do they'll hit detroit and new york
city streets this year
speaking of cars the indie autonomous
challenge showed off a self-driving race
car
one lucky university team will take home
a million bucks
racing it this is a showcase where we
see really the big trends and what
companies around the world are really
trying to move towards
of course there are still fun little
finds like jlabs j
buds frames for fifty dollars they turn
a pair of glasses
into headphones finally how about smart
pepper spray
sabers connected canister automatically
notifies trusted contacts
and the police when you spritz the spray
it will even send your gps coordinates
so help is on the way ces has been
around for 54
years and this is the first time the
show has had to go all digital
because of the pandemic but it will be
back in las vegas
next year now for a behind the scenes
look at this year's show you can find me
on social media
i am at rich on tech i'm rich demero and
you
are tech smart well of course we can't
wait to have all
180 000 people back in las vegas next
year for it you guys
okay so i thought the screen that you
open up to the full 17 inches was
incredible the pepper smart
thing also good the robot pouring wine
what about you guys
what do you think christian i'm all for
the robot pouring a glass of wine i
could do it my partner
sometimes does it for me when he's not
mad at me but i would definitely splurge
on getting that robot
i'll be honest i i don't think rich
demurrer was real i think he's a robot
so i would have rich demurro actually
pour me wine
i'm just saying well we've never met him
before so i guess we'll have to wait and
see right
okay